CHECKLIST FOR HOW THE U.S.
JUDGES COUPS IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> AND THE IMPORTANT THING IS IT
IS NOT OVER.
NOT AT ALL.
MANY BIG LIE BACKERS ARE
CAMPAIGNED TO CONTROL THE
ELECTION SYSTEMS IN THEIR
STATES, INCLUDING A CANDIDATE IN
MICHIGAN WHO PEDALS CONSPIRACIES
AND LIES.
HERE'S SARA MURRAY.
>> Reporter: A VOCAL CRITIC OF
ELECTIONS NOW WANTS TO BE IN
CHARGE OF THEM.
>> IT IS COMPLETELY CRIMINAL.
>> Reporter: KRISTINA KARAMO HAS
NOT BEEN SHY IN INSISTING
WIDESPREAD CHEATING.
>> IT IS NOT RIGHT THAT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF VOTES ARE
ALLOWED TO BE CONSIDERED AS
LAWFUL VOTES.
WE KNOW THEY'RE ILLEGAL.
>> Reporter: AND SAYING DONALD
TRUMP WAS THE TRUE WINNER IN
MICHIGAN.
>> DONALD TRUMP WON MICHIGAN.
>> Reporter: UNSURPRISINGLY, SHE
HAS TRUMP'S BACKING IN HER BID
TO BECOME MICHIGAN'S NEXT
SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> YES, I HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT, WHICH IS MASSIVE.
>> Reporter: KARAMO HAS NEVER
RUN FOR STATE WIDE OFFICE.
BUT GAINED SOME NATIONAL
NOTORIETY AFTER MAKING
UNSUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS THAT SHE
WITNESSED ELECTION FRAUD IN
2020.
>> I WAS A POLL CHALLENGER AT
THE TCF CENTER.
>> Reporter: AS TRUMP EYES A
POTENTIAL 2024 COMEBACK BID,
HE'S BACKING CANDIDATES LIKE
KARAMO AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
SPREAD ELECTION FALSEHOODS.
LOOKING TO REPLACE THE
BATTLEGROUND STATE OFFICIALS WHO
STOOD UP TO TRUMP'S ATTEMPTS TO
OVERTURN THE RESULTS IN 2020.
>> KRISTINA KARAMO!
>> Reporter: PREVIOUSLY
UNREPORTED COMMENTS THAT SHOW
EXTREME VIEWS BEYOND THE 2020
ELECTION RESULTS AND REVEAL
BARBED CRITICISM OF BOTH
PARTIES.
>> THEY'RE A BUNCH OF TRAITORS
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Reporter: HER MOST
INFLAMMATORY LANGUAGE IS AIMED
AT DEMOCRATS.
>> THEY ARE A HAS TOTALLY BEEN
TAKEN OVER BY THE SATANIC STATE.
>> ULTIMATELY THE CULTURE WAR IS
REALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT.
>> Reporter: A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR, SHE HAS A
MASTER DEGREES IN CHRISTIAN
APOLOGETICS, THE DEFENSE OF
CHRISTIANITY.
AMONG HER CONCERNS, EVOLVING
NORMS AROUND GENDER AND
SEXUALITY, VIEWS SHE OFTEN TAKES
TO THE EXTREME.
>> THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
PERSON WITH TWO MOMMIES AND TWO
DADDIES.
THAT IS INCORRECT.
>> Reporter: IN AN AUGUST 2019
BLOG POST, SHE CALLED
TRANSGENDER WOMEN TRYING TO PLAY
WOMEN'S SPORTS MENTALLY ILL
ADULTS PLAYING DRESSUP.
SHE SUGGESTED IN A PODCAST THAT
PREMARITAL SEX PAVES THE WAY FOR
SOCIETY CONDONING PEDOPHILIA.
>> WE NORMALIZE PEOPLE
FORNICATING AND WE NORMALIZE
PEOPLE LIVING TOGETHER WITH
THEIR BOYFRIENDS AND
GIRLFRIENDS, ALL THIS STUFF, WE
OPEN A DOOR TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
NORMALIZE PEDOPHILIA.
>> Reporter: SHE CALLED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS INDOCTRINATION CAMPS.
>> YOU'RE FORCED TO HAVE YOUR
CHILD EXPOSED TO --
>> Reporter: AND IS AGAINST
TEACHING ABOUT EVOLUTION.
SHE REFERRED TO HERSELF AS AN
ANTI-VAXXER BEFORE THE COVID-19
VACCINES WERE AUTHORIZED.
>> I'M CRAZY.
I'M AN ANTI-VAXXER.
>> Reporter: THESE VIEWS UNDER
THE SPOTLIGHT AS SHE SEEKS THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I TRY TO BE
VERY COGNIZANT OF, I'M RUNNING A
STATE WIDE RACE.
I UNDERSTAND I HAVE TO WIN THE
HEARTS AND MINDS OF PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT NECESSARILY THINK LIKE
ME.
>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS
THIS IS JIM ACOSTA, CNN ANCHOR
AND CHIEF DOMESTIC
CORRESPONDENT.
THERE IS SO MUCH -- WE DON'T
NEED MORE EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW THERE WAS AN ATTEMPTED
COUP, FAILED COUP, BUT JUST THE
HEADLINES THAT ARE PILING UP
HERE TO SUPPORT THAT, IT SEEMS
ENDLESS.
>> YEAH, WE HAD A COUP ATTEMPT
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
THAT, DEAL WITH THAT REALITY.
AND WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
I WAS TALKING TO A COUPLE OF
SOURCES ON THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, ONE OF THESE SOURCES
SAID UNLESS MERRICK GARLAND ACTS
AND COMPELS THESE WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY, THAT IS GOING TO
SEVERELY UNDERCUT THE STRENGTH
OF THE COMMITTEE.
ANOTHER SOURCE SAID TO ME, YOU
KNOW, ABOUT WHY THESE WITNESSES
AREN'T TESTIFYING, THIS PERSON
SAID WHY WOULD THEY.
THEY'RE NOT BEING FORCED TO
TESTIFY.
AND WE HAVE A MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE, A GROWING MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE THERE WAS A COUP
ATTEMPT IN THIS COUNTRY AND
BRIANNA, WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW IS A COWARDICE
PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
UNWILLING TO POLICE THEIR OWN
RANKS.
AND UNTIL WE HAVE THAT DAY COME,
WE'RE GOING TO BE CAUGHT IN THE
GRIPS OF THE MAGA COMEBACK.
AND THEY'RE COMING BACK AND
MAINLY BECAUSE WE'RE LETTING
THEM COME BACK.
NOT THAT THERE IS ANYTHING WRONG
WITH A POLITICAL MOVEMENT RISING
UP IN THIS COUNTRY, BUT AT THE
HEART OF IT, WHEN AT THE HEART
OF IT IS A COUP ATTEMPT, AND
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY, THERE IS A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
>> I HAVE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THIS SYDNEY POWELL HEADLINE FROM
JOHN CARL'S BOOK, WHERE SYDNEY
POWELL, WHO IS A FORMER TRUMP
LAWYER, FELL FOR A CONSPIRACY
THEORY THAT THEN CIA DIRECTOR
GINA HASKELL WAS INJURED ON A
SECRET MISSION, TAKEN TO GERMANY
TO SEIZE A ELECTION-RELATED
COMPUTER.
THIS IS PART OF WHAT CARL SAYS
IN THE BOOK, THE SERVER CONTAINS
EVIDENCE THAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS, MAYBE MILLIONS OF
VOTES HAD BEEN SWITCHED USING
RIGGED VOTING MACHINES.
OF COURSE, SHE WASN'T IN
GERMANY.
SHE WAS FINE.
SHE IS FINE.
BUT WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU THAT
THE QANON CONSPIRACY THEORIES
WERE THAT CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I MEAN, I WAS STANDING
OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU
KNOW, AROUND THAT TIME, AND
REMEMBER SEEING MIKE LINDELL ON
HIS CELL PHONE OUTSIDE THE WEST
WING.
I'M THINKING WHY IS THE MY
PILLOW GUY HANGING OUT OUTSIDE
THE WEST WING.
HE WAS THERE TO DROP OFF
EVIDENCE FOR DONALD TRUMP AND
ACCEPTED BY PEOPLE IN THE WEST
WING.
THIS GOES TO SHOW YOU, SYDNEY
POWELL IS ONE OF THESE
CHARACTERS, YOU KNOW,
CIRCUS-LIKE CHARACTERS WHO ARE
HANGING AROUND DONALD TRUMP AT
THE TIME.
I TALKED TO A TRUMP ADVISER
AFTER JANUARY 6th, AND ASKED,
YOU KNOW WHAT WAS SYDNEY POWELL
DOING?
ADVISING TRUMP, ADVISING HIS
TEAM.
AND THIS ADVISER SAID, THESE ARE
ARE THE TYPES OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
AROUND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW.
IT IS NOT THE NORMAL FOLKS WHO
ARE IN THE WEST WING.
OR SEMINORMAL, DEPENDING ON YOUR
POINT OF VIEW, IT IS PEOPLE LIKE
SYDNEY POWELL, PEOPLE LIKE RUDY
GIULIANI, IT IS PEOPLE LIKE
MICHAEL FLYNN.
AND MIKE LINDELL.
IT GOES TO SHOW YOU THE KIND OF
PEOPLE TRUMP WAS SURROUNDING
HIMSELF WITH DURING THAT VERY
CRITICAL POINT IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY.
IT IS FRIGHTENING TO THINK ABOUT
IT.
WHY IS SYDNEY POWELL RUNNING.
GOING BACK TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, WHERE ARE THE
HEARINGS, WHERE IS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WHY ARE THEY NOT
HAULING THESE PEOPLE INTO
CONGRESS TO EXPLAIN WHAT THEY
WERE UP TO, WHY AREN'T WE SEEING
MORE INDICTMENTS?
THERE IS A REAL SERIOUS HUNGER
OUT THERE, BRIANNA, FOR JUSTICE.
YOU AND I REMEMBER ALL OF THOSE
RALLIES WHERE DONALD TRUMP WOULD
TALK ABOUT LAW AND ORDER.
WHERE IS THE LAW AND ORDER?
IT DOES NOT EXIST WHEN IT COMES
TO A COUP ATTEMPT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IT IS INSANE.
>> I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
MIKE FLYNN'S EPISODE HERE THAT
JOHN CARL UNCOVERED WHERE HE WAS
TRYING TO ENLIST HELP FROM THE
PENTAGON TO SEIZE BALLOTS.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, AND MICHAEL FLYNN WHO IS
ALREADY INDICTED ONCE, FOR LYING
TO INVESTIGATORS --
>> HE WAS FRESH OFF A PARDON
WHEN HE DID THIS.
>> FRESH OFF A PARDON, WANTS TO
GO FOR ANOTHER ONE, NOT GOING TO
GET IT FROM THIS PRESIDENT, BUT,
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE
INSANITY THAT WE'RE ALL CAUGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF AT THAT MOMENT.
YOU KNOW, MICHAEL FLYNN IS
SOMEBODY WHO SHOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER,
BARACK OBAMA WARNED DONALD TRUMP
FAMOUSLY, DON'T HIRE MICHAEL
FLYNN.
AND YET HE BROUGHT HIM INTO THE
MIX.
IF DONALD TRUMP BECOMES
PRESIDENT AGAIN, WHAT IS TO STOP
A MIKE FLYNN FROM BECOMING
DEFENSE SECRETARY.
IT IS GOING TO BE A WHOLE LOT
EASIER FOR A SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE MICHAEL FLYNN TO ORDER
PEOPLE TO SEIZE BALLOT BOXES IF
HE'S IN CHARGE OF THE PENTAGON.
ONE OF THE THINGS I, YOU KNOW,
EXPERIENCED, BRIANNA, COVERING
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THERE
WERE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, VARIOUS
LEVELS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, WHO ARE WILLING TO
SORT OF PUT THE BRAKES ON THE
CRAZIES INSIDE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, AND FORTUNATELY
THAT'S WHAT WE SAW IN THIS
EPISODE.
THERE WERE PEOPLE IN THE FLYNN
EPISODE ACCORDING TO CARL'S BOOK
WHO ARE BASICALLY SAYING, NO, TO
MICHAEL FLYNN.
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING OVER TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND SAYING WE
NEED TO GO BACK AND RECOUNT
THESE BALLOTS IN VARIOUS STATES.
THERE ARE PEOPLE AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SAYING, NO, SO, I
MEAN, THANKFULLY WE DID HAVE
PEOPLE AT VARIOUS LEVELS OF THE
GOVERNMENT WHO WERE PROTECTING
THE CONSTITUTION, WHO IS TO SAY
THAT'S THE CASE NEXT TIME.
>> LOOK, THIS WAS A STRESS TEST.
IT REVEA